women hate it
they'll say something like this is
misogyny or standing what submission is
in the context of a healthy relationship
they they think submission and they
think oh being a slave or lowering
yourself for a man or being at his
backing call or having no opinions when
submission in a relationship isn't about
that at all it really means that you're
just trusting a man's leadership and
that you respect him to the point where
even when you have disagreements you're
not nagging you're not shouting at him
you're not emasculating him so when
women understand that then the word in
itself submissive it's so it triggers
people
so I know you said um you mentioned deep
program you had to deprogram a lot of
that stuff what was like the turning
point for you
when I the turning point for me was when
I built my own business I scaled it very
successfully and because I got so much
praise for it I kept thinking okay my
value to a man comes from how much money
I make the more money I make the more
they're going to see me as different
from the other women so the turning
point for me was when I looked at my
history of date and thought to myself
why is it that no men like me what if
it's not the man's fault what if it's my
fault so then I started reading books on
dating and books on men so I could
understand men and women and the common
theme that kept coming up was that
masculine men don't like masculine women
they like women a woman who's in touch
with a feminine and a woman who's open
to receiving so then I started making
those changes in myself and that's when
I actually got a boyfriend but that's
really powerful because most women don't
do that they don't do that
self-reflection they don't read and most
people don't read the books about
relationships but no most people want a
healthy successful relationship but they
never research or read books on healthy
successful relationships and most women
want a
they want a man that is that is able to
lead they want a masculine man but then
if they're not going to be submissive to
somebody who's leading then it doesn't
actually make sense if they're not going
to be submissive so if you'd like if a
woman is like okay well I don't want to
be submissive well then what you're
saying is you want a a man that is equal
or below you yeah but then they'll go no
no no no but I need a man that makes six
figures but you don't make six because
this doesn't actually make sense yeah
not to mention submission is a very
beneficial thing for the woman too if
you're super career driven if you're
making a ton of decisions if you have to
lead a team in your business don't you
want to relax when you're outside of
business and let a man handle things
like
I also think like to add on to what you
said people suck at taking
accountability
we always ask ourselves like on my tech
talk so I post like dating stuff for
women
a lot of women will comment saying oh
where do you find your boyfriend where
can I find these men or men are trash
but no woman saying what do I need to do
in order to become in order to attract a
better quality man it's like a
submissive submissive there's only one
person can drive a car at a time so you
can't grab the wheel off of them so
people find it a weird word to use but
only one person can't be in control what
do you say to women that say they want
an equal partnership
then you have to deal with the fact
you're not gonna get the traditional
benefits of a man like he you he's going
to want to split the bill
I love that like it's true right like
he's if you want to be equals with a man
then you're not don't expect the
benefits that a masculine provider man
is going to give you
you can't have something without giving
something else back absolutely you know
so that's your point right now I just
had a little brainwave and I was like yo
I can technically build a house
but I don't have six figures a month
or six figures a year not even close
is this is the type of women that goes
for the six figures men it's not every
woman that has that mentality of like I
need to have a man that has six figures
you can get a man that's his figures and
maybe can't even construct a sentence
together I mean I think that's what
women say but then you watch who they
date and it's a different story I've
seen a lot of girls come on my show and
they'll like say something that sounds
nice and then after I'll look at their
dating history and maybe he's not rich
but he sure as hell is quite handsome
and like top 10 20 and so maybe it's not
rich but like
yeah I mean not to not to disclose any
any information or that's only two sauce
about me but um up until like a year and
a half ago I didn't have a bed
but yeah I was still engaging with
sexual activities with women to the
point where they were like you should
get a bed
not right now because I don't need one
I'm a relationship it wasn't until I got
into a full-on relationship I was like
yo I'm I could marry you tomorrow and
not feel no type of way about it I don't
care what my family say I don't care
what they got to say I'm in love with
you and you are in terms of the roles of
the relationship
like she was willing to learn I was
willing to learn
and she was feminine and I was masculine
yeah you know what I'm saying like for
example we I would finish a hard day at
work she would finish all that work my
house or your house your house okay cool
yeah I'll get around there food's cooked
my favorite lemon drizzle cake whatever
and then you know what I mean it was it
was feminine and she come to mind I'd do
the same thing because that was our
roles in relationship in a sense of we
don't live together but in this but if
if I'm coming to Abode UK are for me
yeah do you remember me
so in that sense I was like yeah life is
good why don't you why do I need the bed
for and that mattress on the floor is
good
that bed soon came though and that woman
came to the Limit
she said what she said one line and I
said okay cool next day I'm on eBay
looking for beds you know
you see it's that that that goes back to
what I was saying earlier right about
communication skills yeah you see some a
lot of women would communicate things in
an aggressive way which doesn't cater to
for one of a better word than male ego
so therefore they're not going to get
them whereas if she says it in a certain
way or ask a certain question rather
than makes a statement then it becomes
like okay I want to do this for myself
and for us rather than I'm being forced
to do it by somebody else Jazz all she
said is babe you need a bed that's it
that communication thing I don't think a
lot of people are very honest in
relationships anymore
so I
I was dating this girl a few few for
about three weeks I was seeing her on
the weekend before she moved away and
for the first two weeks she mentioned
she said the words no I don't want to
have sex she said it's okay for me not
to have sex and the second one she said
is it all right for us to never have sex
and I said what never that's a long time
I joked about it and then the third week
we were more intimate than I thought but
we didn't have sex and I kept talking to
her
and eventually I had a conversation with
her saying like what would you have
improved of me if I could find something
out and she said I never made a move
and I was just and she doesn't remember
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible